don't go buy milk and bread that you
don't need because milk sandwiches are
not going to get you through the store
[Music]
what do you think titus what do you
think this precipitation is going to
bring us huh
what do you think it's going to be rain
let us know he says i don't know
i don't know i'm just going to stay in
my shelter the whole time
or maybe i'll just lay in it because i'm
a dog that likes it cold
all right so we are dealing with some
serious winter weather that is coming
our way in georgia
georgia is not the kind of state that's
prepared
for snow and ice accumulation on the
roads
we don't have the infrastructure for it
because it's such a rare thing that
happens here
that we don't have
the big salt trucks and snow plows that
some of the northern states have so
there's a lot more risk involved with us
getting an ice storm
than in other states and areas of the
country winter storm izzy
is headed our way this weekend
it should be here tonight and in all day
tomorrow we're expecting
rain ice snow
really all the models are showing
something different and nobody really
knows what to expect but there is a very
high probability of the ice being the
most common thing that we experience
and that can be really bad news for the
homestead and the state of georgia so we
have to get prepared to make sure that
our homestead and family and property
are all safe from the coming storm
[Applause]
i don't know if you can see but peaches
bill bowser and
peter pepper are all snuggled together
in the buck shelter
some things that we want to take into
consideration
with the animals is to make sure that
they have proper food water and shelter
so for the water what we do is we fill
up every trough
that we have on the property we also
fill up every five gallon bucket we can
find with water that way if there is a
power loss which is very likely in these
ice storms we will still have water to
give the animals
and we also need to prep for water for
ourselves
miss piggy and her three gilts are nice
and warm inside their shelter
we've got a solid roof
somewhat partially solid walls and lots
of nice bedding we will be adding an
extra layer of straw
for tonight's
weather as well
for their food we always give lots of
extra hay
for them to eat when it's going to be
cold or bad weather in general where
they're going to want to stay in their
shelters for the majority of the day and
not be out browsing we need extra hay we
also usually give extra grain in the
evenings to help them stay warm through
the night and that goes for all the
animals cows
goats pigs poultry
they all need just a little extra boost
to warm them up as they burn through
those calories
yes oh
good puffer
this has got his shelter
he's got the solid roof and then a tarp
over this part of it
so he can get in out of the weather
but
he's a good job yeah she's a good boy
khaleesi has
her dog house here and she most of the
time goes under the barn where she likes
it the best
we just recently acquired this dog house
she does not want to go in it so i'm
going to try giving it to titus and if
he doesn't like it then i'm going to
give it to the guinea hogs
but they have all this lush spring
growth that is just
incredibly healthy and vibrant right now
and i'm hoping that the ice doesn't kill
too much of it
all right titus what do you think
are you gonna go in there
got a bunch of
straw in that dog house
got a bunch of straw up in that hog
house
that's the one he's used to he likes the
space i think he seems like he's not
that into this one because it's kind of
small
you let us know
if you don't like it we'll give it to
the pigs
okay
yeah oh sit on my foot
thanks
goofy dog
you love your tartar
we also make sure that their shelters
are sound and secure we evaluate each
shelter to determine its strengths and
weaknesses
and make sure that if there's anything
that we know is going to cause a problem
we go ahead and repair it or improve it
now that might look very different for
people in colder climates but we're not
even going to get below 32 so we're not
as worried about a low temperature
harming any animals as we are
making sure that they stay dry because a
wet cold animal is bad news
but if you can keep them
from getting wet in the first place and
make sure that they have a nice warm dry
place to rest they will be just fine in
32 degrees
so it's not so much the temperature as
it is the precipitation that is a danger
to our animals that we have to make sure
that we are prepared for
so this is our recent
change to the buck shelter we took the
small blue tarp off
and covered it with a much larger
tarp
given
extra lean to area for other animals to
take shelter that weren't going to
cuddle up in here
inside the buck shelter
we have lots of hay to keep them
warm and toasty and it's deep litter so
it stays nice and warm
but we're gonna be making some changes
because
the roof does not hold water correctly
it'll pool and it'll start to cave in
because we just have these boards kind
of haphazardly holding it up
so ryan is at lowe's now getting some
roofing material that we're going to
replace this top with
one of the things we do is on top of the
deep bedding that's been accumulating
over the year that warms up at night for
them and keeps them warm and cozy as
they snuggle together
we also add extra hay
for the ones that don't have a thick
deep bedding in their shelter we add a
good amount of straw straw is a great
insulator as it has hollow
stems and that provides an extra layer
of insulation oh yeah that's a lot of
straw to bed down in i think they're
gonna like that
what do you guys think
you can come check it out
come on
[Applause]
yeah
oh you're gonna eat it huh you silly
girl
go bed damn in it
she's like that's not food
okay so something just occurred to me
that could be a problem
when i was over here
getting
the
pigs where are we
right in there
i can see them shuffling around
um
they love the straw by the way
but i had to unplug the electric fence
so that i could climb over and put it in
there
and then i
went to go plug it back in and i'm like
oh
if we lose power
this group of animals can get out
now once they get out
they do have some perimeter fencing but
it's mainly barbed wire which is not
gonna
you know it's a foot off the ground the
little pigs can go right under it no
problem and mama could go under it if
she wanted to
so
we are gonna have to keep an eye on
things most likely they won't know that
it's off
and we'll be safe and they'll stay
inside the fence and they won't try to
get out but if they do then we're going
to want to
lure them into the buck
shelter
and
hope that the board doesn't mess with
them he's the only one i'm kind of
worried about peaches is in heat and she
is a little bit moody right now so
i don't know if she would be dominant
acting with miss piggy
but it would be the safest place for
them if they do get out but i don't
think that's going to be an issue
cross my fingers
we also like to make sure that all of
our animals have a buddy have a friend
somebody to snuggle up with that helps
keep them warm
right now the way we have it set up
because lashes keeps getting out
unfortunately she's not going to be able
to snuggle with her mama tonight but her
mama has the best shelter on the
property so she's going to be just fine
this is the shelter i'm the most happy
with i find that it is
provides the best
comfort level
and this is friendship shelter
the chickens also
tend to go in here and sleep with her
they usually lay their eggs in the
corner
they're there
but we do scoop out the poop
every day the big clumps
and make sure it's a nice thick layer of
hay for her to bed down on
that provides warmth as well so those
are the things that we do to make sure
that our animals are going to stay
dry and warm
well fed and well watered through any of
the storm issues we might face
the biggest issue that we do encounter
here where we're located in georgia we
are west of atlanta in carrollton area
and we do often lose power
in these bad types of storms
um there's a lot of rural areas where
the power lines have trees that fall on
them causing power outages that could be
widespread meaning it might be a couple
of days before we get our power back we
are crossing our fingers and hoping that
that's not the case so as far as prep
goes for losing power there's not a
whole lot we can do because we don't own
a generator we don't have a wood stove
if we did we would be making sure that
we had tons of firewood inside to keep
us warm
but we're just gonna have to have all of
our blankets ready and we're gonna have
to all sleep in the same bed if we have
to if it's cold enough but it's not
likely to get that cold here having a
generator would be ideal we do have a
few friends that aren't too far away
from us
that have been willing to bring us a
loaner generator in the past so if worst
case scenario comes and we lose power
and they don't then hopefully we can
phone a friend
yes james i might be calling you
so
having other friends in the homesteading
community around you is an important
thing because you might need to reach
out to them for help with firewood or a
generator or getting a roof on a shelter
that's not quite stable enough for the
rain that's coming ahead
so reach out to those people in advance
let them know that you're hoping that if
you need any help that they're available
and also think about the people who
might be in a worse situation than you
that you can help um we recently offered
firewood to a friend of ours that's
slightly north of us that gets
temperatures that are a little colder
and they heat their whole house with
firewood they were running low and we
offered oak firewood but unfortunately
it was too green for them to use still
just try to do what you can to help
others check on your neighbors check on
your elderly
community make sure that you know that
the people around you are safe and
protected and that they have everything
that they need to get through the storm
whether it's food water or warmth
having a heat source is a good idea for
your house that's a backup heat source
that can keep you warm when you don't
have power we don't have that here but
we have had our heat
not working
in the past before we got it fixed
and it was temperatures as low as 32 and
we stayed pretty warm inside so i'm not
too worried about that but if you live
in an area that's colder i know some of
our waters are even in canada where it's
getting negative 20 degrees
then you might want to reach out and
find out who lives near you that has a
alternative heat source so that you can
go to their house and stay warm extra
water is extremely important during a
power outage and a winter storm
so our well runs on power so when the
power goes out we have no water source
so we are going to be filling extra five
gallon buckets with lids for our water
source we're also going to be filling
our bathtub with water so that we can
flush toilets we're also going to be
filling all of our extra food grade
buckets so that we can have drinking
water and water to cook with
cooking that's a whole nother
issue if you don't have propane
or gas
stove and you only have electric then
you have no way to cook
so have an alternative cooking source
for us it's our grill we got plenty of
charcoal we'll we have food that we know
that we can put on the grill and cook if
we need to but having other foods that
are easy to prep or don't have to be
cooked is really important don't go and
buy
10 packages of food that you don't need
from the grocery store and end up wiping
out the shelves don't go buy toilet
paper you don't need don't go buy milk
and bread that you don't need because
milk sandwiches are not going to get you
through the store
what you should do is get a little bit
of the things that you know you will use
in a couple of days time it's only a
couple of days that you won't have power
if that so don't be greedy make sure you
lease enough for others because there
are people who are wiping the shelves
clean and making it hard for people to
actually have what they need you also
want to evaluate your property
especially around your houses or other
buildings making sure
look at the trees evaluate any branches
that are overhanging around your house
and see if there's any trimming that you
need to do to make sure that you're not
going to have any limbs falling on your
roof another good step to do for people
especially in the farm
is to
put an extra layer of mulch in the areas
that are muddy or that get puddles of
water so that you can have a safe
area to walk across so
if you just get a couple of wheelbarrows
of mulch and dump them on your pathways
it's going to save you a lot of
heartache
when the
storm is here and you're having to go
out there and take care of animals in
the storm it's much easier to walk
across a layer of mulch than it is a
thick mud pit and we have a few of those
here that we need to address
[Music]
it's also good to know how you're going
to keep the ice off of the water for the
animals the animals are going to want
their water
to be free of ice they would prefer that
you warms them up for them if you don't
lose power and you can warm up a bucket
of water for your animals it is a good
idea so
have a way to break the ice
and remove it from the
water for the animals and do that
frequently
also don't forget to make sure you know
where your candles lighters and
batteries are for flashlights
if you need a light source you're going
to want to know where those are before
the power goes out
if you have a weather radio make sure
you have batteries for it that's a good
idea to keep on hand all of the time
overall just remember to be safe don't
go out on the roads if you don't have to
and stay inside as much as you can if
it's bad weather
so check on the animals frequently
but you don't have to spend a bunch of
time outside just make sure that they
can get to their water and that they
have food and for our family we're
making sure we know where a deck of
cards
and a few
board games are so that we can have fun
if we do lose power
we won't be worried about which devices
aren't working or how netflix isn't on
we'll have each other to have fun with
and we'll play some games and really
have a fun family time
having a power loss can actually be fun
for family with kids
if you make it that way
don't let them get scared or worried
make sure you show confidence
make sure you show confidence throughout
it so that they stay feeling safe
and make it fun make it like a picnic or
camping out and just teach them
different ways that they can do things
without power i hope that everybody
stays safe and sound through this storm
and that nobody has any damages from the
ice or power loss
make sure that you
check on the community around you and
make sure that your friends family and
neighbors are all safe and warm too
so as we are out here working trying to
get everything ready for the storm
it is noticeably colder
every hour that we work the temperature
is definitely dropping
we have sent the boys inside to snuggle
up and watch a movie while we finish up
what we have to do out here
and
i'm getting a little chilly i might have
to go get some gloves
[Music]
all right that's a roof
[Applause]
what do you guys think you excited
peaches is already in there
checking it out
peter pepper's waiting and here comes
lashes she says i'm coming in too
and we're getting all this mulch put
down
where it was muddy
so a nice path
for easy travel all right
ryan is finishing up the last touches
he's putting walls on the shelter to
block from the wind
i've added straw to the beds i've
oh i think we've done everything we can
do for tonight i've mulched areas that
needed to be mulched i filled up water
buckets
now we just have to give everybody
a little extra food for the night to
keep them warm and they'll get a little
extra food tomorrow night to keep them
warm
and we should be good to go and i did
the i didn't get it on film but i
reinforced the chicken coop
shelter
for them to block out some of the wind
so
everybody should be good for tonight the
storm should be starting around midnight
it's gonna start out with some rain
turning over to ice
probably turning over to snow after that
but we really don't know even now the
forecast is all over the place depending
on who you talk to
so wish us luck and hopefully everything
will be
safe and sound here on the homestead and
remember to be storm ready and prepare
as best as you can and make sure you
check on your neighbors